[Music]
dan Kobo Yu When you make drugs, you have to think about money and make it,
so it's a price in
your
mind.  As
you can see, the [music] that was created over the course
of 375 years is like this.  However,
I think that being able to run with things like your own way of life, your own hometown, your own family, etc. is
attractive
.  The
name is Yoshikazu Yamada, and this car is called Ryuyumaru, and
he has a few years of experience.
Because it's a product I'm proud of
, my name is Shokai
Kikuchi.In total, I think there are about 10 million causal car alarms going off.Running with the
lights turned on beautifully
heals my heart.
People say that things are scary, but
if you look at the sky, you'll see these cute colors and cute
traps
.
I think it would be great if people could feel that feeling of being happy, even just a little